the reason why there's so many time
management techniques is because none of
them fundamentally work so people keep
going in search of new ones and creating
new ones because they lack the
fundamental skill of discipline why does
discipline matter well in a world where
time is finite as we've just discussed
you can only do so many things so I try
to write a simple equation why does the
goal matter to you plus the
psychological enjoyment you get in the
pursuit of the goal minus let's call it
the psychological disengagement or the
psychological friction associated with
the goal and so the reason it's
important to think through that
framework is you can influence it if
there's something in your life where
you're not disciplined you can focus on
that first half of the equation remind
yourself why this really really matters
to you and then do everything you can to
make the pursuit of the goal as
enjoyable and as engaging as you can